et le Tony Award de la meilleure pièce va à l'
imagerie Duncan merci beaucoup oh mon
Dieu je tiens à remercier mon merveilleux
mari néerlandais Peter Kelvin elekid que ha ouais
ta mère et moi pensons que la meilleure
chose pour toi en ce moment as-tu dit que la
mère le ferait  sois pour que tu sois dans le
confort et la sécurité de ceux qui t'aiment
inconditionnellement salut chérie dis-leur que tu
m'aimes inconditionnellement
Hey Oh mais laisse-moi prendre place à l'arrière de
ta voiture et verrouille les portes d'un casino
te garer c'est ma conception de petit ami ouais  salut
George Bush en fait ce n'est
pas mon nom
bien jr.  en arrière tu regardes c'est différent
j'ai mangé beaucoup de spaghettis Oh
Oh mon Dieu les cheveux pour ça qu'est ce que tu fais dans
ma chambre en
fait c'est ma chambre
suis je le seul ouais
vous avez fait l'amour